[Music]
in can't have nice things news this is
why we can't have nice things
that's me and white t-shirts yep every
time tell you're wearing black met you
with David never seen you wear white
shirt Mister Rogers one but there's a
big ass he'll if he wears a white shirt
there's always something huge here to
come you know last week while running a
white t-shirt and the dress shirt on top
guess what happened I spilled a burrito
on me build a burrito exactly what
happened oh because I went to that
burrito joint right across you know last
TECA or whatever and it was hot and
fresh and I was like I'm gonna just wait
til I get home and eat this and what
happened was it didn't happen and so
that whole burrito flipped this way and
went all on my but it was too hot to do
that so I just had to let it happen just
had to deal with it and now that shirt
is done submitted by Joe's dream ready
hmm
what is that like at the castle's I
don't know the bishop of a popular
Chapel on a Greek island has called for
a ban on all foreign weddings
after sexually graphic photos go by oh
that's my dream wedding that's what
they're trying to say what submitted by
Joe's dream wedding and this is my dream
wedding that's what they're trying to
say yeah yeah that makes sense looking
in a Greek chapel yeah I do like gyros
gyrating with some dye rows it was some
job yes a big one though you just drank
boogers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he's like that monkey with that no it's
done it - I like that and you [ __ ] you
got bring it this couple from the UK
this is British couple they went to this
very very popular destination wedding
Island it's a Greek island called Rhodes
and there's this church there's this
chapel Club st. Paul's Chapel and this
is like super popular for British
couples to go here and get married and
so when this couple and they Matthew and
Carly they decided to do like a funny
photo pretending that the bride is the
groom oh wait who's supposed to see
these photos cuz these are usually for
your family and loved ones they posted
this on their Facebook page we planned
this photo they thought it was gonna be
hilarious but then all of a sudden it
just went crazy viral and now it led to
the Bishop of this island and like this
Chapel saying like ok because of this
stupid-ass couple no more for wedding
chapel so this is that couple it's so
interestingly even the source of white
people they're very much like American
white people like UK that's like the
source that's where they came from the
source of Chapel was like somewhere in
the background but yeah like this was
outside of where that was all you know
this is interesting I didn't know that
Greece or the island of Greece looks
like a apocalyptic desert with white
usually does it's like this
yeah it's like white it's like white
sands and like blue water yeah it's
gorgeous
where's the trees ain't no trees and
green honey like me
Oh treason Yahoo you know that she cuz
it just looked like rocks in the ocean
this island in that Chapel it gets
sucked yeah it was my dream to go there
and you really cancel yeah so as of
right now there's weddings like they're
booked solid all the way up to 2021 god
there's like hundreds and hundreds of
couples at now they're just like they're
panicking panicking and they're just
like hoping because this still isn't a
final decision but it's gonna take a
couple weeks for them to reach a final
decision but the bishop has called for a
band and so now everyone's shooting for
its place you know what the bishop is
the bishop is like that teacher because
one student messed up now all the
student and everyone's like can play
with the school freaking with the
classroom snake you know like one kid
does some stupid thing and then everyone
else can't play with their like pet
hamster yeah feed the goldfish or
whatever now and everybody feel like
Bart was always that clear I didn't even
get to try it yeah I'm more like that
dude that was during like training
during the wrestling team that wouldn't
run properly so everybody had to run
again yeah well it's because mr. Shaw
won't do is push-ups for him doing like
a girl this is like the adult version of
that the bishop's like well if you can't
behave you can't be here and they're
like blood bishop that's a community
leader of that area that he says like
he's been getting hundreds of calls from
soon-to-be brides and they're just
crying
the groom's don't give a [ __ ] god you're
like we'll get the same some money yeah
I'm just saying that they're just crying
and just saying like not all British
people are like that it's just these all
of us all of us not all of us want to
suck dicks and be in a photograph yes so
now there
couple if the ban does end up happening
and then this couple is for sure going
to get sued by so many people yeah you a
bishop no no couples oh I wrote in their
way oh no you had a good job earlier -
you [ __ ] it up she's high off that one
and one one good job one
yes I'm like for example this couple
here you've already planned out their
wedding you look related yeah yes what
happens scene man at d-day fool you
start morphing yeah I'm gonna get
blue-ice or she's gonna get Asian eyes
actually they keep saying that she looks
Asian
oh yeah and she starts speaking like a
father that's good you're saying that
Isaac is looking more and more like
Casey is growing up that's trippy well
the only thing agent about Jess is the
fact this you know she's just like
gardeners or money watashi de she why
she has a really pail Korean skin other
than that but every time we try to spend
[ __ ] she goes you're not gonna need that
getting too much money and she's always
right yep always right so she gets mad
when I spend too much money even on her
that's not Asian really right that's a
asian mom that's right she's a mom yeah
he's an Asian mom cuz the Asian
girlfriend will spend all your [ __ ]
money and tell you oh that purse wasn't
good enough yeah unless you're Julia
this couple yeah they were complaining
saying like they would be suing that
other couple if their wedding is
canceled because they've already spent
tens of thousands of British pounds on
their wedding they've already booked
their stay they their whole family has
booked everything so there's like how
does that work though why do you sue
someone because they were the cause of
you losing me for your damages probably
they have a stipulation that Church has
a stipulation where they could cancel at
any time here so they're protected under
that as well their same people although
they get married now all people you love
2.10 judgmental eyes they do in 30 their
are you serious he weighs the same as me
I know I'm just trying to say like
they're not that old but oh they look a
lot older though I got 10 they are boats
all that Sun this one they're both 32 oh
yeah they're at 30 and 32 yeah I don't
think so dude I'm 34 and that yeah I
don't know about that I don't know about
that Wow so Dan I'm gonna be even if I
get like horrible I'm gonna take a
bottle of water here I know a lot of
vegan people that look at all this [ __ ]
though today about nutrients [ __ ] and
you're next to him whenever you're not
sitting next to him and never happen oh
shut up I just updated it to the new
thing so I had I don't know how to use
it like that they're the same pictures
no it's not the same it's shaped
differently there are different places
now yeah there's a driving mode now it
doesn't get you a little okay yeah so
you are getting married by him let's say
bad should happen at your wedding venue
what's your reaction I would be pissed
more so like because I know cheer would
be super upset you know I'm saying cuz
like even like like we it's a year away
we've already booked through the venue
and like her family's already looking at
like where they're gonna stay when
they're all out here yeah so there's
like a definitely a lot of planning that
goes into it I'd be super pissed when I
sue that couple though if I already put
the down if I already put an initial
payment in you have money sure they
won't give it back to you
they don't even got money how are you
gonna sue them when they can't even pay
well maybe not just about the church but
everything else involved in the wool
wedding okay that's how cuz you could be
losing out a total like 100 grand or
something like that like deposits on the
catering and all yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah what would you do if Americans were
banned to go to France and none of us
could do the wedding and then I find out
like a month before yeah daddy's booked
because someone jacked off at the Eiffel
Tower
yes no no it's an American that did it
that's why shirt you choose you know
that's one they're banning all foreign
does it matter who it is no matter where
they come from no one outside of Greece
can get married about this this island
that's mean that's racist yeah well at
least for this though it's not that bad
because at least we can try to find like
a different location within the Greek
islands
hmm I think the biggest fallacy is the
fact that I don't understand why that
picture was funny yeah you know like I
get the the [ __ ] it's loot but what
there's no connection to it you could
have done that anywhere so what why was
that picture funny cuz it's at their way
she's in a wedding dress I guess I think
it's cool there's a picture like that on
top of a hike on a very tall mountain
that's tight but there's context there's
guy that there's no context to this
there's no challenge behind this what's
the context in that one I haven't seen
you're like on top of the world your
life like you hiked all the way up to
the peak just to get a [ __ ] so it's
like you worked really hard for
something that you could do anywhere I
get the the contrast of like you're in a
beautiful place you're in your wedding
gown and you suck at some date like
that's that's kind of like the most
basic form of okay I get it hey sorry
like not gonna give beautiful man maybe
the church has to just change their idea
of do they're married so they're not
violating any rules this is on church
property they're not married yet yeah
it's right outside the chapel yeah man
is disrespectful yeah that's crazy
disrespectful sacred Brown kamasutra
Church I'm saying you could have went
you could have went like down the street
to the beach yeah and then done that and
suck his dick you know yeah they should
have done that somewhere else where it's
accepted like Amsterdam mmm thanks for
watching guys and those are our thoughts
what are your thoughts don't forget to
comment below we want to know what you
guys are thinking but don't write
anything that will make it sad or make
us mad because after all we're just
kidding news and we're a very happy
channel for the last video click up here
[Music]